okay
this might surprise you i think that
hassan
and us
contribute to anti-trans sentiment
possibly
yes but i think for like different
reasons definitely yeah that's not
surprising
okay
so i haven't taken time to reflect and
think about this quite a lot you know
because believe it or not we don't just
put out [ __ ] we try to use our brains
every now and then
um
some of us just think we just wake up do
youtube and go back to sleep
today's topic
the whole trans topic is an interesting
one
because
most people
don't interact with trans folks in their
lives
by most studies that i've seen trans
people account for maybe one percent or
less uh than that of the population so
it's not like it's a huge number of
people and unlike a racial group or
biological sex transness is not easily
seen on somebody somebody can have
gender dysphoria identifies trans and
you looking at them won't know so you
may actually be interrupting the trans
person and not know it
okay so the way that the vast majority
of the public
interacts with transness is through the
media
okay the most polarizing the most like
extreme stuff right because that's what
the media does the media is trying to
get your emotions and your heart strings
going because the fact that that's what
generates views to them so everyone's
takes are on polarizing issues and
income everyone's favorite dinner topic
right trans women in sports okay you
might be wondering why trans women
because trans men in sports are
invisible all right they don't win
anything kind of like the usa soccer
team okay
[ __ ] losers all right maybe this
[ __ ] transition they'd win some
but they don't
they're invisible so this topic comes up
it's polarizing it's super polarizing
and the people who are jumping on this
topic are the most polarizing folks
possible they're they're going at it
from every political angle and so
i see myself and i'm commenting on this
topic that's in the news because we
cover trending topic and this one
especially but i had to ask myself why
has this one in particular for me not
for you nearly as much but for me stuck
around and you know what i realized
would you realize
and we will wait what's stuck for you
this topic of trans women yeah it really
still is more for me than for you oh
definitely so i had to think about why
we covered and how that negatively
impacts because if everyone is just
seeing the most extreme stuff and
they're hearing like well yes uh uh
trans women should be competing in
sports and trans women and women if you
disagree you're a [ __ ] big that's how
people are internalizing trains that's
the only perception that they have most
of the time okay other than watching
euphoria or some [ __ ] so
and we had to go ahead but we had a lot
of people a lot of trans people comment
on this [ __ ]
and be like no i agree what they say
so a lot of people there's a lot of
trans people that agree with what we say
but that's not what we're going to
highlight
we're going to highlight
extremists
for good context yeah
there's some level-headed people who
said a lot of interesting mind stuff and
we could have covered that but we went
for the [ __ ] uh
a dad is fat phobic and transphobic
because that [ __ ] makes your eye pop out
but it's not it's not so much for the
content because it makes it up about
it's because there's a lot of proportion
of people that actually think a certain
way and we might have to add address
that because we disagree on that but
yeah content to me i'll tell you why
this and why that specifically sticks
out to me and this is the go ahead
we live
in this city which is hyper-liberal yes
we live in a country that is generally
leaning very left
we also work in a field in the arts that
also leans left super left okay
super so my entire life i've always been
surrounded by the lift i've always
identified in terms of like what i vote
for be it socialized healthcare um
social programs for for those who are in
need in terms of like taxation for
people who make a certain income and
keeping that high to be able to fund a
lot of stuff i'm for a lot of these
policies right and even socially i'm on
board with most of it
but i've also witnessed over the last
maybe decade or so
how the site that i've always identified
with has engaged in a lot of weird
censorship
sanctioned violence and just overall
behavior that i find extremely
reprehensible
and i've told you this it's not
right-wing folks who are [ __ ] with me
nowadays it hasn't been that for a
decade more the people who signed me at
comedy shows the people who do all this
crazy stuff are the folks who are
supposedly on the same side right most
of the time right and you always notice
this with these people there is a
complete disconnect with reality and the
way they feel like the world should be
right that is a consistent theme when
they're telling black folks you can't
talk about your experience because i as
a white woman feel like that's uh racist
like [ __ ] who are you telling me
what black people can or can't say
like you guys went from like fighting
four [ __ ] to try to tell [ __ ] how to
fight for themselves that's what hassan
does oftentimes too no no white women
you're just a trans person you are just
a trans person sorry you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about i've been
hearing i've been hearing
liberal white folks trying to tell me
i'm just a black person you don't know
i'm like [ __ ]
white woman went from telling us what to
do to telling us what to do
that's what happened that's a buck
that's a bar so i want you to repeat
this and so in comes a lot of this like
performative activism that's zero based
in logic and sense right
and then comes a trans woman issue where
it feels like [ __ ] are trying
to convince us that the sky's orange and
if we don't agree we're a [ __ ] bigot
and i'm bugging
you want to get to the bathroom go ahead
i don't care you want the pronouns that
you want go ahead i don't give a [ __ ]
you want medical care that trains women
go ahead i don't care i'm for it
i disagree with the trans women sports
[ __ ] bigot whoa can we slow this
[ __ ] down
can't we and it reminds me again of
everything that i've seen for the last
decade yeah so when i'm
coming at this yeah i have to
acknowledge my own advice and my own
motivation the motivation is like [ __ ]
these [ __ ] been annoying the
[ __ ] out of me forever and this topic is
like the
the [ __ ] bad batman like in gotham
everybody see that [ __ ] this is the one
that highlights it the most it's like
these people have lost the ability for
any common sense and so
that's what's charging me when i'm
coming at this discussion not dishonesty
because i would never lie to get my
point across i would never try to
misrepresent but i do acknowledge that i
play into the polarization or the um
hypersensationalism of this topic i 100
do and that's something i need to watch
for why because here's an example
someone told me this another streamer
told me this but he said something i
thought was really smart shout out to
destiny he said if some content creator
was coming out and constantly make
content about how the fact like black
people you know the big problem that you
guys have in your community is rap music
and this and that like
hyper focal like focusing on this even
though there may be some truth to the
fact that some of the aspects culturally
don't
uh perpetuate the best values per se you
know [ __ ] [ __ ] get money okay
one can acknowledge that somebody hyper
focusing on that and doing 30 videos
about why rap music is killing the black
community may make folks look at him a
little bit sideways correct so flat tv
you said black tv hey [ __ ] you on a
roll today i'm just saying hey today you
got time listen yeah you said vlad tv
if you know you know and a lot of people
who know vlad tv no man
that dude the amount of people he's
marked on crazy
but but but here's my point so in that
sense when all i represent is that in
the media for the viewers who watch me
or for the viewers who are watching the
discussion unfold all they see is the
hyper sensationalized stuff so that's
their only perception of transness you
ask most folks about trans folks they'll
be like i don't feel like they should be
competing with women when vast majority
of trans folks do not want to or don't
think it's the right thing either they
don't agree with it but
but there's twitter and there's us okay
and we're part of the problem so that's
the accountability i and we have to take
in that regards would you agree where
i'm like oh no i agree you agree i agree
yeah i have been doing the most time but
i've been told yeah man you're on that
[ __ ] again but you're also
participating too i'm not saying no yeah
yeah cause you know i always got time
yeah yeah yeah like i told you i was
robbing the bank but [ __ ] you didn't
get out the car you just said hey man
it's a bad idea you're sick it's a
terrible idea they get
that was you
so so in that regards that's the
accountability we have to take going
forward in regards to how we cover this
now here comes the other side okay
because we've taken ourselves let me
explain the other side
when you
get on these platforms and try to
convince folks that the sky is orange
when it's not
and you tell them their biggest if they
disagree and that they have internalized
bigotry because they don't believe in
the orange sky that you believe in
they start to look at you a little crazy
like yo this person considers themselves
like an advocate or some kind of leader
for this community or some [ __ ] like
what else is this [ __ ] lying
about
this man really just sat here and told
me filing fox is one and five i went on
google the [ __ ] is five and one yeah
pretty much undefeated well i went by
can you see that why are you lying where
the the trans woman fighter uh is it
fallon fox
had like one or two
uh victories
and has lost
routinely but you never hear about how
much she has lost since then everything
that he says yeah everything you should
check everything that he says why is he
moving the goalposts first it was trans
women don't have an advantage now if
they don't have a sizable advantage and
now it's like no trans women are women
so what it doesn't matter now it's like
everybody got advantages so shut the
[ __ ] up it's like you see the goal post
and you start to look like damn you're
funny and by proxy here is a cis male
okay who is not trans who does a poor
job of advocating for trans women in
sports and unironically makes more
people polarized as a result because the
fact that he's a liar and then this is
this is the nefarious part trans people
are negatively impacted by the fact that
this guy's trying to represent them and
when a trans person has come forward and
said hey you probably shouldn't done
that debate because when you went up
against a [ __ ] tick-tocker and lost
embarrassingly you made trans folks so
bad and this man told them you're just a
trans person shut the [ __ ] up imagine
that that you tell the people you're
trying to defend and represent to shut
their mouth
if that isn't the biggest form of
performative activism you've ever seen i
don't know what is tan's relationship
with the trans community is interesting
he once lost a trans-related debate and
people in his community were rightfully
upset with them because they felt like
he made them look bad my issue as a
trans person is the fact that you a guy
that isn't super well versed on trans
[ __ ] brought on a known transphobe
knowing he might bring up transphobic
[ __ ] you aren't exactly a vashta trans
debate i hope
i hope
that
the rest of your life is as horrible as
it is every single day okay there you go
suck my dick i despise you
i despise you more than anything else on
the planet you are [ __ ] cancer you
are just a trans person sorry you don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
and that's where i hate
from the deepest fiber because i can
acknowledge and despise somebody who's
against me who's racist whatever and i
know where they stand but the people who
pretend to be allies the people who
pretend to fight for me and then you
realize oh wait this is just woke
twitter points so you can look good to
your [ __ ] fans and [ __ ] oh those
people i [ __ ] hate there's a deep
sense of hatred in them than me for them
because i'm like oh you brown nosing for
this and you know what's crazy a lot of
these so-called lefties and so i'm
ranting today i'm gonna go in
a lot of these lefties they'd be like
yeah man we want to hear a fight for
black folks you realize they don't have
black friends or they don't know black
people because you talk to some of these
political streamers who are hyper left
and talk about this i'm like you do
realize that black folks are not for
lgbtq stuff they're not for gay marriage
they're hyper conservative in terms of
the social views they're like what
what you you didn't know this
but you realize that there's a complete
disconnect between the people they're
defending and themselves because again
it's just about the optics
and as a as a minority
i find it super distasteful when the
plight of minorities is used
with zero concern for the people who who
are who are being really impacted by
this for [ __ ]
social media clicks that's why i hated
it when people posted the black square
or they're like blm but [ __ ] i saw you
saying racist [ __ ] about black women
last week like the [ __ ] is you talking
about okay
like no i i don't rock with that stuff
so when somebody feels like yo why are
you getting so
these are the same people who i witness
literally cancel
other black communions in my community
for the most my new stuff right
minorities are just speaking their mind
they [ __ ] got them rid of them yeah
and so i realized like oh the enemy used
to be the skinheads now it's these
[ __ ] yeah you know they're the
ones that are problems you know betrayal
don't come from the enemy it comes from
the allies
right bars how's the bar you can't give
yourself a bunch
that was listen i give you bars when you
don't even ask for it yeah but i'm
telling you that one yeah that's not a
ball that's a bar that's not a boy
that's the bar
is that i've been from the past years
and past [ __ ] years i've been
harassed by police yeah all the time
it's not even them that bothered me no
more it's not them
it's not the police yeah
it's these [ __ ] yeah
police is cool yeah
police is cool it depends on where you
are some of you might be making
communities where police still [ __ ]
yeah i'm just saying we've seen the
difference over the last decade ever
since the phone cameras i'm not saying
they're great people but it's not it's
not like it was before no it's nothing
like it was before and i think most
people would acknowledge like racism
today is not what it was before what is
it some [ __ ] up comments there's still
some [ __ ] yeah okay but anyways all
that to say the one that bothers me the
most and then really
are
a detriment to what i do in my work this
is y'all it's y'all lefty yeah
and [ __ ] i'm left
you know what though go ahead i thought
you wanted no i was done
the thing about being a lefty nowadays
is like you either tow the entire line
or [ __ ] you on the other side yeah yeah
but you said that to me the other day
but i want you to think about that the
way i view people's political
affiliations is i give you a score out
of six
and there's certain points i'm gonna ask
you questions if you're with it you get
a point if you're not you don't and if
you don't get above a three out of six i
don't consider you part of the group
yeah okay
so you asked i'm like are you first
socialized healthcare
okay are you for maybe protecting class
blah blah blah you go through the list
but with these [ __ ] you go
through this right and here's the weird
part
you can be for socialized healthcare you
could be for taxation you could be for
social welfare programs you could be for
strong labor unions you could be for all
this stuff
then you'd be like i'm not with the
trans women as well oh you're a
right-winger you're a right-wing
operative
yeah that's it it just takes one it's
just and it just takes one and the worst
part is it takes the most insignificant
one but you told me you know what i'm
saying yeah
it's not even the whole point the whole
translator it's like a point two
because you could be for the trains
within the bathrooms the the [ __ ] um
the pronouns you could be for the
medical care the more important [ __ ] you
say no other sports you're not part of
the group i want you to see the
psychosis i know but
that we've had to endure but you you're
hanging in the arts you can meet yeah
i know i know i saw this [ __ ] [ __ ]
crazy he's [ __ ] going in no no
no because it's been repressed for a
long time god damn it has hasn't it yeah
it has it has it has and it's flared up
for us yeah it's flared up a few times
but you told me some [ __ ] that was very
smart the other day what well a couple
of years back oh a couple of years back
and you said to me you said yeah
you said yo do you realize that the
right hasn't moved
i was like huh yeah the right hasn't
moved no
it's like
the right has always been like the
extremists you know it's always been
like nazis and [ __ ] like that but they
haven't moved they pretty much stayed
whatever the [ __ ] they are you know i
mean over there
and let's say you're in the middle
but left leaning okay
you're center left leaning
you didn't change because your center
left leaning
and it's the left that moved
more to the extreme
and then the more they're going to the
left the more they're looking back at
you in the center and they're like yo
you're closer to the right than us
because we're over there
you're closer to the wall you said if
you're staying to the wall like that and
i'm here
you're going to be closer to me but
let's say this is considered the middle
you're going to be closer to the left
than the wall right
but if i start moving
and i walk and i walk and i walk and i
walk and i'm like hey
i turn around and i'm like hey
you closer to the wall than us
you're with them but you haven't moved
and the wall street haven't moved is the
left [ __ ] that went over there
see what i said a couple years ago
that's a bar
i was about to say
yeah but i was gonna say because i
already knew
i said it years ago well [ __ ] you then
bars
bars all day
i have a question would you say it's a
rod
no it's a bar it was a whole ass bar try
to demand what i put over the foot i
said it's a whole ass bar but i said was
that hey betrayal don't come from the
enemy they'll come from the allies
bars i believe it's malcolm x or maybe
it was martin luther king but he said
something about the fact that it's the
white liberals that you have to be
terrified
i wanted to get this point across
because i want you guys to know that
even though we've had this channel for
seven years there's been evolutions
throughout this process this is another
one for us
you know through dialogue with people
and having good conversations i realized
like you know what focusing just on this
issue a lot i can recognize the ways in
which it contributes negatively you know
and
i have
the
draw and the benefit of being in the
arts and so as a result i've had the
benefit of being around a lot of lgbtq
people okay
now
for me it gives me an ability to see
translates in all its delights and all
the positivity and
i have a human perspective of them
you may disagree you don't know me but
that's okay that's what i'm telling you
i think for a lot of people who only get
to see it through the media i think
different representation and not just a
hyper fixation on just this one topic
which dominates the news all the time
is necessary but so long as these people
continue to say the most absurd things
to defend this pretty much indefensible
thing
it will always contribute to more
anti-trans sentiment
you get what i'm saying so this
discussion is going to unfold whether
we're part of it or not and whether we
repeat those talking points or not
but
the conversation can move forward once
the other side stops seeing the most
nonsensical things because they're held
hostage by [ __ ] ideologues that make
no sense so long as that's the case it
will never move past so
um
i just wanted to be able to share that
and then from there
yeah you know we had a we had a back and
forth with um
her name is sam something samantha lux
samantha looks yeah
he had strong disagreements with
samantha looks regards to jokes
contributing violence
but throughout the whole entire process
i never thought that
this person was less than human i never
thought of misgendering them i never
thought they were lacking respect i try
to be charitable and think like this
person's not coming from a negative
place we just strongly disagree and i
still hold that opinion i think we can
have strong disagreements in this world
without
it being hyper polarized to the point
where we dehumanize the other side and i
would
recommend to our fans and to anybody
who's watching to learn more about
translation to not just dismiss it
because all you've ever seen online is
the most ridiculous stuff and i agree
a lot of it is ridiculous a lot of it is
polarized and we probably contributed to
that some degree but i do not think it's
the whole picture and i think if you
want to be someone who's educated on
this topic there's a lot of good
resources out there for you to learn
from um so maybe we'll post a couple
links in the discussion uh in the stuff
below
maybe you're going to have to see
through tv shows and media i don't know
but uh just try to keep an open mind
that's all i'm saying anything else nah
so that's it for us let us know what you
guys think in the comments
now that was a rat today you're sweating
from that [ __ ]